everybody the royal family the dimelios
are here they are known
[Applause]
first family of tick tock I think you're
the first family of social media
um but here's some fun facts you might
not know did you know that Dixie was a
sick BMX biker ranking fifth in the
nation
where is it visiting with you guys and
fun fact about Charlie she got 15
tattoos in one year I like it thank you
they're like this big I I'm looking I
don't see any on you there's some on my
fingers they're so tiny there's one
right here oh they are yeah on my back
they're very small all right well please
welcome everybody Charlie Dixie Heidi
and Mark dimelio
now
out of curiosity Dixie and Charlie like
how do you navigate having hundreds of
millions of followers having millions of
people know who you are for I feel like
we don't think about it I mean we do
what we do and like we Post online but
we just try to live our lives hang out
with their family we live together we're
roommates so we come home at the end of
the day and are like sisters and just I
think it's also still having that
connection with the people that knew you
before and you know my hometown friends
are a big part of my life my family is a
big part of my life and you know I'm
still their daughter at the end of the
day and they have rules and I have to
respect my parents and she's still my
big sister and it feels the same so
boundaries what is your advice for
having extremely recognizable kids on
social media and what's your advice for
parents who are just going God I didn't
sign up for this in our generation chin
I mean I think for us like we they the
foundation is what we set with the
boundaries where your parents were not
you have friends you don't need friends
you need parents and rules and
boundaries but so from what they knew as
kids that didn't change when all this
happened on social media that stayed the
constant and I think them knowing that
this is what it is and it still feels
the same Health what is your advice to
parents out there who are you know
having kids or even themselves trying to
build a life for themselves on social
media because that is a really amazing
new opportunity for everybody in a
positive way yeah I think the tone the
has changed over time we're now everyone
understands that you can make a career
on social media so I think it's up to
parents to get involved but not to be
the center of attention I think Heidi
and I have tried to balance it out where
we're involved with with the process but
we're never trying to overshadow the
girls it's their show we're just along
along for the ride now Switching gears a
little bit I do have two daughters
sister advice when should I lean in when
should I lean out yes we like hated each
other like absolutely hate each other
what ages Middle School all of middle
school until we went to gone to high
school together then we became best
friends like she would come with me to
every party on the weekend like it just
happened out of nowhere though so like
we would go weeks without talking like
and we lived we were we shared a wall
yeah but now I don't remember the last
time we've actually argued yeah over
anything and now we live together just
us too so that's pretty fun I noticed
the times where it gets the most
annoying when we fight is when they
chime in and they're like what are you
guys arguing about maybe
fights I think that makes it so much
worse because we're done oh my God
this is such I think I feel the same way
that's my gut instinct I'm like let them
work it out not about everything or when
it's dangerous obviously we all know the
line but yes yeah oh my God thank you
I'm so sorry this is such great news now
anytime they get involved it makes it so
much worse and then we just get mad at
them like oh my God
they'll argue she's texting me she's
calling me about the other one so so
what do you do how do I do this I step
in okay I start telling her just listen
I try to like tell to just listen I try
to tell each other where the other one
was trying to come from meanwhile
they've already made up I'm he and I are
still like okay so what should we do
whatever and they are so moved on I'm
like you know what I'm not doing this
anymore like we're going over here you
guys figured out and I don't do it I
don't get involved anymore okay it took
a minute so helpful you know okay wait
you guys are doing Dancing with the
Stars
together yes so how do you do that how
does that work well we tried the whole
smack talk thing for like a few days
right and then I was like okay I'm done
with this because as my competitor you
know I can't come to you and be like oh
my goodness I'm so stressed so we can't
do this and then I also have to keep in
mind that she is my mother and I you
know I can't be too mean about the
competition thing
but I don't know I feel like I mean we
we've never competed against each other
in anything so it's we're learning yeah
but I'm like I'm our biggest cheer I'm
both of their biggest cheerleader I
don't think that's gonna ever change but
like at the same time I'm competitive so
I want to win too so can we keep going I
don't know this is new this is
definitely a weird feeling for me as a
mom to you know it doesn't feel right so
I'm I'm figuring it out I don't know how
that how you get through that and I mean
you are known as a dancer you are an
incredible dancer I have watched all
your videos I love your incredible I
mean you're such an amazing dancer but
other than dancing if you were to have
to pick a lane an occupation what would
it be
um
do you remember what you used to say no
you wanted to be a psychologist because
you had a lot of bad therapists oh yeah
that was that was one thing because I've
had my fair share of very bad therapists
I thought you wanted to run a hotel oh I
forgot oh yeah I was going to go to
school for
um Hospitality I was going to go to
college for that and be on the dance
team well maybe you could have a therapy
Hotel
yeah either one of them right yeah it's
like a really good vacation I'm not
kidding actually why is this not a thing
[Music]